[Musique]
un jour il est venu me voir il m'a dit
il m'a dit comment on fait pour rentrer
dans la mafia
je dis mais
lui il rentre dans Mafia
il me dit ouais je voudrais rentrer dans
la mafia
je sais que du jour au lendemain on peut
te demander d'aller tuer quelqu'un comme
ça de sang-froid dis-moi que je m'en
fous moi je suis n'importe qui de son
français
cimetière de Thiais dans le Val-de-Marne
Fadila rend visite à une amie disparue
il y a 3 ans
ce matin là elle lui a écrit une lettre
bonjour Nadia
je t'ai perdu ma tendre Nadia un
après-midi bien ensoleillé tes yeux en
amande des tombeaux sourires doux me
manque hamlarkem Nadia
ma chérie je t'aime
a été tué d'une balle dans la tête dans
le hall de son immeuble à Grigny dans
l'Essonne
c'était le 5 avril 2012
elle rentrait tout gentiment de son
travail pour aller chez elle
pour me préparer un café
Nadia la Seine est la dernière victime
d'une longue série de meurtres qui a
semé la terreur dans les SNES il y a 3
ans 4 assassinats en 4 mois sans mobile
apparent dans un rayon de 10 km le tueur
en série agissait toujours à moto pour
les enquêteurs une course contre la
montre s'est engagée pour l'empêcher de
tuer à nouveau la police a fini par
interpeller un homme yoni Palmier qui
est-il vraiment comment la police
a-t-elle réussi à arrêter cette funeste
série de meurtres
récit d'une traque hors norme
l'affaire commence le 27 novembre 2011 à
Juvisy-sur-Orge
c'est dans le parking souterrain de
cette immeuble qui a eu lieu le premier
des quatre membres
Florian loisi et journaliste au Parisien
il a enquêté pendant des mois sur le
tueur de l'Essonne
c'est ici que Nathalie David 35 ans a
été retrouvé morte
tué par cette ou huit balles dont une
dans la tête elle a été retrouvée
étendue par terre juste ici devant sa
voiture
personne n'a assisté au meurtre de cette
jeune laborantine mais plusieurs témoins
affirment avoir vu dans les heures qui
précèdent un motard casqué immobile dans
le parking impossible d'identifier cet
homme
rapidement les enquêteurs partent sur
une autre piste celle de l'amoureux est
conduit
et ils interpellent l'amant de Nathalie
David Michel Courtois
pour la police le scénario semble
évident leur relation était orageuse et
le mode opératoire cette balle dans le
corps ressemble à un crime passionnel
sous pression après 40 heures de garde à
vue Michel Courtois passe aux aveux
c'est là qu'ils ont dit pour aller à
vous à vous à vous que c'est toi vas-y
on va passer une bonne nuit tu vas
rentrer chez toi tu as
pas moi et à un moment donné mon j'ai
craqué quoi j'ai tellement fatigué
tellement que j'en avais très très marre
tu dis voulais savoir vraiment vous
voulez savoir la vérité vous savez vous
voulez apprendre ce que vous voulez
entendre dès que c'est moi puis voilà
qu'on en parle plus du tout
quelques jours après devant la juge
d'instruction Michel Courtois se
rétracte il dénonce des aveux extorqués
mais il est mis en examen et incarcéré à
fleurir mes Regis pour la police
l'affaire semble bouclée pourtant elle
ne fait que commencer
deux mois plus tard le 22 février 2012
deuxième meurtre dans le même parking de
Juvisy-sur-Orge à la même heure
cette fois-ci ces gens Yves bonne rue un
cadre de 51 ans qui est assassiné d'une
balle dans la tête avec une arme de même
calibre que le premier meurtre un
pistolet automatique 7,65
une fois de plus aucun témoin mais des
résidents ont à nouveau aperçu un motard
dans le parking comme pour le premier
meurtre quelqu'un en moto casquette rien
de précis si ce n'est qu'un voisin qui a
déjà donné une description précise de la
moto qui est une GSXR une grosse
cylindrée sportive de Suzuki
voici le modèle de la moto qui aurait
été vu pour les enquêteurs les
coïncidences sont troublantes ils
pensaient avoir arrêté le meurtrier mais
le même scénario s'est reproduit au même
endroit et ce n'est pas fini
trois semaines plus tard troisième
meurtre à 6 km dans la commune de
Ris-Orangis et la même moto réapparaît
le tueur a démarré en trombe après avoir
assassiné Marcel Brunetto c'est ancien
employé de banque de 81 ans est mort
d'une balle dans la tête dans le hall de
ce HLM yann villemare est le gardien
c'est un locataire qui nous laissait
tous les jeunes du quartier qui
connaissaient tous les locataires qui
avaient aucun souci et on comprend pas
on comprend pourquoi ça s'est passé
comme ça on comprend pas ce qui lui est
arrivé pourquoi c'est sur lui c'est
gratuit c'est gratuit
là encore même calibre même mode
opératoire dans le même secteur
aurait-on à faire un tueur en série
la question ne se pose plus qu'en 3
semaines plus tard le 5 avril 2012 un
quatrième meurtre à lieu dans la commune
voisine de Grigny
Nadia lassens s'effondre mortellement
touché dans le hall de cette immeuble
dans son quartier l'émotion est immense
incompréhension et inquiétude ce soir à
Grigny devant l'immeuble ou Nadia la
Seine 48 ans a été froidement abattu
hier d'une balle en pleine tête un
quatrième meurtre en 4 mois dans
l'Essonne sans mobile apparent le fils
de Nadia la scène nous a dépenses matin
une maman sans histoire elle avait elle
avait aucun compte à régler avec
personne à laver elle avait pas de
problème elle avait rien du tout j'ai de
la haine j'ai de la colère j'ai de la
tristesse j'ai envie de la faire revenir
je veux qu'elle revienne quatre meurtres
de sang-froid par armes à feu dans un
rayon de 10 km 4 victimes qui n'avaient
aucun lien entre elles la traque du
tueur s'annonce difficile
les expertises balistiques confirment
les soupçons des enquêteurs c'est bien
la même arme qui a été utilisée pour les
quatre mœurs ce point commun finira par
innocenter Michel Courtois le suspect
incarcéré depuis le premier assassinat
pendant ce temps dans les scènes la
psychose s'installe la police lance une
chasse à l'homme il faut arrêter le
tueur avant qu'il ne recommence
des centaines de policiers le long des
routes de l'Essonne c'est un vaste
dispositif de surveillance qui a été
déployée aujourd'hui principalement
recherché la moto du suspect une Suzuki
semblable à celle-ci
les policiers épluchent plus de 300
cartes grises de moto GSXR et vérifie
l'identité de chacun des propriétaires
possède une carte grise falsifiée c'est
Yoni Palmier
est-il le tueur en série et qui est-il
exactement à 33 ans il est sans emploi
déjà condamné pour des faits de violence
[Musique]
unipalmier a grandi à Ris-Orangis parmi
9 frères et sœurs père absent mère
dépassé
adolescent introverti il souffre
d'exclusion et de brimades
[Musique]
Alain triboule l'ancien principal de son
collège se souvient d'un élève paumé
quand on est comme lui en situation
d'échec scolaire et social c'est c'est
un peu normal qu'on finisse par
être un peu révolté et l'école
exclu il faut reconnaître que c'est un
peu ça malheureusement
au lieu de
d'aider les enfants à bien trouver leur
place il y en a qui la trouve jamais et
il fait partie de cela
yoni Palmier quitte le système scolaire
à 20 ans sans aucun diplôme ni formation
à l'époque il rencontre Franck
trébouilloire cet ancien animateur de
radio se rappelle un jeune homme
sympathique mais très seul passionné de
musique
gentille drôle
marginal évidemment mais il était
solitaire toujours seul sa camionnette
son vélo mais toujours très seul il
rentrait seul à la maison seul seul tout
le temps Yoni Palmier vit alors de
quelques aides de sa mère et
d'allocation sociale qu'est-ce qui
aurait pu le faire basculer dans la
violence ce qui est sûr c'est que son
comportement devient de plus en plus
inquiétant pour les gens qui le
connaissent comme José Torres
et il a commencé à mal parler de sa mère
en l'insultant de tous les noms et je me
suis levé je l'ai regardé j'ai dit on
parle pas comme ça de sa mère on
respecte sa mère et là il est parti mais
dans une colère mais mais
impressionnante j'étais obligé de le
calmer mais il avait une voyelle dans
les yeux qu'il avait une une haine
profonde
un jour je la butterai
le jeune homme se montre même de plus en
plus fasciné par les armes et la
violence
[Musique]
la journée vous voir il m'a dit il m'a
dit comment on fait pour rentrer dans la
mafia
il me dit ouais je voudrais rentrer dans
la mafia
je sais que du jour au lendemain on peut
te demander d'aller tuer quelqu'un comme
ça de sang froid dis-moi je m'en fous
moi je suis n'importe qui de sang-froid
il n'a pas hésité il a pas hésité 2
secondes mais moi je le prenais pour un
mytho quelques semaines avant la série
de meurtres Yoni Palmier semble basculer
et avoir un projet très précis
c'est ce qu'affirme ce témoin qui
souhaitent rester anonyme un professeur
de physique que Yoni Palmier avait
contacté pour un cours à domicile
et voilà j'ai un stage à faire j'ai un
projet professionnel je vais faire un
lance-flop il faut que ça soit un lance
flamme un gros con ça la flamme alface
presque à mettre donc je me suis dit ça
c'est une arme
Yoni Palmier avait même conçu un schéma
de son lance-flamme
il était déterminé c'est à dire en santé
qui pouvait aller jusqu'au bout pour
construire
selon ce flammes et j'étais très mal à
l'aise
que voulait-il faire de son lance flamme
mystère
le professeur a immédiatement cessé le
cours et n'a jamais revu cet élève
en examinant le profil de Yoni Palmier
les policiers découvrent un casier
judiciaire chargé des faits de violence
répétées il est finalement arrêté le 14
avril 2012 soit 9 jours après le 4e
assassinat
pendant sa garde à vue il conteste toute
participation au meurtre pourtant Yoni
Palmy va de lui-même conduire les
policiers à des indices accablants il
indique aux enquêteurs ce box louer à
son nom dans lequel se trouve une moto
identique au modèle recherché le
voisinage décrit un homme fuyant et
solitaire il sauvait dès qu'ils voyaient
quelqu'un ou alors il se renfermé des
fois la porte était ouverte il entendait
une voiture à arriver il refermait sa
boucle
deuxième découverte à Draveil
dans un autre de ces box les enquêteurs
mettent la main sur plusieurs armes dont
le pistolet automatique utilisé pour les
quatre mœurs
Yoni Palmier est mis en examen pour 4
assassinats
aujourd'hui cela fait 3 ans qu'il est
incarcéré depuis sa cellule il a écrit
une lettre à son seul ami dans laquelle
il clame son innocence et donne des
explications confuses
je suis une star du crime maintenant
indépendamment de moi il faudrait que je
t'explique certaines choses
tu comprendras mieux
qui a des gens qui ont tout manipulé
voilà il me dit pas me voir ça me ferait
du bien et puis et puis il me dit je te
jure j'ai pas fait tout ça et j'ai pas
répondu enfin la police m'a demandé de
répondre en fait et de pas y aller
surtout
c'est sans doute cette ligne de défense
que Yoni Palmier va suivre à son procès
d'après son avocat Julien Frénot son
client est innocent selon Yuni palmier
d'autres personnes auraient commis les
meurtres il les désigne par un nom
mystérieux le groupement
la problématique c'est qu'il ne donne
pas énormément d'informations sur ces
personnes puisque ce qu'il explique
est-ce qu'il a dit à nos nombreuses
reprises c'est que pour sa sécurité par
crainte de ses tiers il ne veut pas
donner plus d'informations
à ce jour la justice n'a trouvé aucun
élément confirmant la version de Yoni
Palmier cet homme que tout désigne et
pourtant sans mobile demain il sera seul
dans le box des accusés pour répondre
aux questions de quatre familles
endeuillées